then let's go start going boys
first out chicken liver parfait very
strong that you wanted to be that strong
it's one of the main elements because
I'll see that's where we highlight the
tops yes we're fine we like the hurts
and we just want to other things
workarounds advice next up featured
risotto with pickled fennel and bravely
trout sous-vide the fish is vacuum
packed and cooked in a warm water bath
so it's texture remains unchanged it's
daring to experiment like this but you
can't alienate the customer they need to
understand what's being served to be
able to appreciate it
I mean customers come here for the first
time you have to explain to them we have
a pink very very pink I do still do it
stops the confusion she challenged me on
what I'm saying rather than just
accepting that I didn't like it and I
feel it wasn't properly which then very
hard it's crucial to keep customers on
side am um Susan has to take
responsibility for that front of house
we're not in the 1980s and if a customer
was there fish cooked a little bit more
two seconds two minutes whatever it may
be you get it done
next up quail with celery root puree on
a pastry nest it's also so very rare and
again customers should be told
when we asked how thee quiet was cooked
I went around and said what got7 you
have to get used to
I didn't hear I didn't really appreciate
that too much I'm worried by how much
food is coming back uneaten
mother love is a wonderful thing but
keeping the truth from your chefs is a
mistake did you ever get feedback from
the diners absolutely yeah yeah
when pretty much our base night most
nights yes and what kind of feedback do
you back Peter and Juliet normally
really positive everything's the only
ones really perfect pretty smooth I get
complaints in my rations that's the only
way I've learned because you constantly
get feedback on a daily basis not always
great and blowing smoke up each other's
ass you only learn from negatives not
the positives